thanks guys I'm crystal Martin I am the
organizer of Kotor girl in the community
and education engagement manager at
launch code just very quick launch
called the organization here in st.
Louis that gives people with jobs in
tech so Kota girls an extension of that
and i like to say we're kind of like a
rap roof right now so like everyone the
state is not going to talk but like it
Heitmann because coder girl is really a
hype men and women cuz Kota girl is
really a community effort this is not
something that I organized every week
this is something that we collectively
make happen so what is colder girl will
coda girl is all of his programming meet
up like I said it happened to every
Wednesday here in st. Louis and what we
are focusing on is just getting more
women in tech in the space here and
network in st. Louis and so we encourage
that connection and community and we
also encourage learning and so just to
talk a little bit about the learning
trax do we have it coded or so every
week a Carter girl we have these
learning tracks and so we are working
with a variety of different languages
and frameworks one of them we are using
the harbor entered the computer science
course foundational course to get people
started in tech Java with Jenny back
here jenny is an awesome mentor and
she's going to talk about her project
later on but she has developed a course
on udemy it takes you from knowing
nothing about Java to being able to
build projects in Java and then we have
a sequel servers and databases group we
have an awesome mentor named Kathy
Kellenberger who was like the sequel
guru and she's teaching women secret
code a girl and then we have a web
development and design group which we
are also going to have some
presentations on and we also have
hardware hacking with Arduino DH with
Jessica so we're playing around with
some of that stuff in coming up with
cool projects for that in the next
quarter so I will let the mentors take
it away all right I was totally not
informed that this picture was going to
be on the slide I'm halina converse I've
been working with the web development
and design group basically our goal in
doing this is trying to take web
development and making it something so
that it's not
so heartily to get into it because
there's a lot of different languages and
frameworks that are involved in just
making a simple web page that like looks
pretty so we basically go through and
take people through HTML CSS we're
taking people the PHP route for doing
back end and then sticking javascript in
on front of that and for our project
this year we wound up going through I
guess it was this semester we wound up
going through and actually started
building us a coda girl website as
opposed to just having like a page on
launch codes page so we're hoping to
really get that picked up and running so
that we can get stuff out and over there
all the way on the right is our coder
girl website one point O celebration
yeah you have it up we're going to show
the website so this website is all
mirroring all right so what we wound up
doing for the website was just going
through and figuring out what the base
things that we needed we had some fun
designs going through and getting that
all set out and then the coder girls
were going and looking at that and
figuring out how to make it run and one
thing that makes me very proud is from
step one they decided to do mobile
responsive as well so I'm very proud of
them okay who's up next
so I am introducing people to Java
development as there's quite a quite an
offering for jobs in that area and quite
a need for developers one of the things
I noticed was that classes tend to have
a gap so they introduce you to
programming the introduce you to
object-oriented design and then there's
this big technology gap before you're
ready for a job you need to pick up
databases you need to pick up web
development you need to pick up full
stack and so along with that comes
although the teamwork you need get you
need revision control you need to know
how to work with the ticketing system
and how to plan and scope your work and
do it iteratively and the classes don't
really cover that very well you need a
team you need to be working with a team
so team projects are the second step in
this learning process for the folks who
are learning java on the team projects
they divided into small groups three to
five people and come up with their own
idea for an application and then based
on their interests they spec out what
it's going to include I help them keep
it to a small version to begin with so
we can do it iteratively and then from
there we figure out what technologies do
you need to do this what do you need to
go learn to get comfortable with those
technologies and how are we going to
break this down for a group to be able
to work on together so I've got two
groups right now who are working on team
projects one of them is doing a roommate
finance tracker and the other is doing a
recipe program and they're encountering
a lot of interesting details along the
way that result in people pairing result
in people researching stuff and bringing
it back and presenting it to teammates
and these are all skills that are doing
a great job of getting them ready for
their for their jobs and in fact out of
eight people currently working on team
projects I believe three of them have
been placed in jobs and one is very
close to doing so so we've got a pretty
good success rate going here so the team
environment really does a lot to help
them keep moving along
after your past the basic academics of
what is programming and what do I do
with it there's how do I serve my
teammates and how do we build something
awesome together and so supporting this
team project process has really given
them encouragement to look beyond what
they've encountered to reach out to the
hard stuff and learn cool new stuff and
be ready to go on the job so that's been
my focus with the Java team projects hey
my name is Ricky and I helped lead the
project that is the continuation of cs50
for those of you who don't know cs50 is
the Harvard's introduction to computer
science class it is taught in C and that
provides you know a bit of limitation we
can do afterwards and for my project at
least we kind of just you know come
together we come up with ideas and I let
them kind of you know just brains from
what they want to do without the
limitation of Technology and then we
take their idea and move it forward in
this case we decide to make a game we
try to imitate asteroids if something
would like to plug that in and we did it
in Ruby and if we can show it I also
like to thank j down there who's part of
lambda lounge who was who came on as a
random mentor who helped a lot with the
project and cats good for me
oh this is probably not going to work
because the resolution is hard-coded
because we never got that far but
surprise it's asteroids going over some
of the details of the projects out
roughly we're trying to structure it as
a quarter system so the teams have you
know about 12 ish weeks to come up the
ideas get it working go through the
technology go for it you know those
trials and tribulations that really help
you become a good programmer and learn
all the tools required for it alright so
that's code a girl in a box keep in
touch with us like I said it's an
awesome program everyone who's on this
stage has done so much to make it
awesome and we have so much fun every
week there are 35 to 40 quarter girls
who show up every week we have 15 to 20
mentors who show up who are professional
programmers here at companies here in
st. Louis and so it's a lot of fun if
you're in the area come and join us
we'll be at the CIC which is on 4240
Duncan in the cortex area every
Wednesday six to eight and you can get
involved anyway if you want to come as a
mentor if you want to come just as a
participant hang out be our photographer
if you're not in the st. Louis area and
you like what we do promote us make
other people excited about this and so
we are on the slack channel you can talk
about it we can hang out here at strange
loop that's our website on the launch
pro website cutter girl 1 will be up
very soon if you have any questions you
want to reach out that's the email
address and we're on facebook twitter
and meetup com thanks so much for your
attention